for injured service men and women in
america
the battle continues here long after
they've left the front line
amputated limbs are visible and enduring
reminder of the cost of war
at the height of the afghanistan
conflict the walter reed military
medical center was treating
200 amputees at once but the hidden toll
of combat can be equally devastating
uh they're angry um they've either lost
friends
a battle buddy or it's rare that they
haven't
they want to go back and even up the
score
then they kind of realize well i'm
pretty pretty beat up myself
jeremy yost watched his best friend die
on the battlefield and still struggles
with flashbacks
i couldn't even go down the street
without seeing a piece of trash on the
side of the road and think that there
might be a roadside bomb
even here in the united states he also
suffered a groin injury which left him
infertile
nearly ending his marriage we almost got
divorced
we we had a hard time uh having a child
it took about six and a half years for
us to have a child
we just were able to have a baby three
months ago
2312 u.s military personnel have died in
afghanistan
most buried here in arlington cemetery
in virginia
every gravestone represents a family
torn apart
but few have suffered as much as bo wise
he was one of three brothers who served
in afghanistan
now he is the sole survivor jeremy was
killed first in 2009 by a suicide bomber
in 2012 ben was gravely injured in a
fire fight
and died six days later how do you
cope with that much trauma as sort of as
one
person you know losing two brothers it's
the nature of the jobs that we chose and
what we did
and every deployment is a roll of the
dice
what i felt most guilty about was
that i wasn't a parent and that jeremy
and ben were
nearly 800 000 americans have served in
afghanistan
some weren't even born when this war
began with the news of the withdrawal of
troops they're left contemplating
whether their sacrifice has been worth
it martha kellner sky news washington dc